Luke here at the outo boys YouTube
channel and I'm deep in the Alaskan
mountains I'm crossing glaciers hiking
through deep snow hunting for rock Tagan
seeing the northern lights and camping
in one of the most beautiful survival
cabins you'll ever
[Music]
see the last time I did a hike like this
I froze my butt off got caught in an
early winter storm and had to take
shelter in a survival cabin in the
mountains well now I'm on a different
Trail in the same mountain range it's
10° colder and we're going to do a
rematch I got to be a little more
careful this trip I slipped last time
and cracked my elbow on a rock I think I
fractured it because it's been over a
month and it still hurts when you touch
it I'm starting this hike off in the
warmest part of the day and it is just
right at
freezing look at that wall of mountains
yeah I got to get over
that that Beaver Pond is all Frozen up
Beaver is going to spend the next s
months stuck under the ice the only way
they'll breathe is by going into their
dens or going to little push-ups that
they carve out underneath the ice it's
hard to believe an animal can spend the
entire winter doing that without Wi-Fi
I'd be so
board the wood foundations to a building
right there and this is an old stove
you'd build the fire in here and then
you would cook in there there used to be
a lot of gold mines in these
mountains last time I didn't bring my
rifle so I was guaranteed to see
tarmigan which I did so now I've brought
my rifle so I'm guaranteed not to see a
tarmigan there's two type of Tagan in
Alaska there's Rock Tagan and Willow
tarmigan Rock tarmigan are a little bit
smaller they live high up in the
mountains amongst the boulders they're a
game bird kind of like a grouse or a
wild chicken if I can get one I'll have
fresh Tagan Stakes for dinner
tonight fun part's over now I got a
grind uphill for 2 and 1 half th000
ft see these big boulder piles that's
the kind of place you're going to see a
rock Tagan you tend to also see pasas
marmots and Parky squirrels in those
Boulders as well
this steel cable is what's left over of
a trolley system the miners would get
their ore and supplies up and down the
mountain with a trolley car and they
would take it down there into the valley
floor where we saw those
ruins this is one of the trolley
platforms see the cables go all the way
from the bottom they keep going up this
hill
this snow is really old but there's tons
of rabbit tracks in it got to keep my
eye out for Snowshoe
hair I can hear a pika up in the Rocks
up there chirping at me pikas are kind
of like gray Alpine Geral and it's the
animal Pikachu is based off
of this Trail is really slick in places
I might have to change into my cleats
here here oh there's a fat little puffy
Pika right on the tip of that
rock oh see he was just sitting there on
the tip of a rock suning himself that's
exactly what I want to see a tarmigan
doing such a huge temperature difference
when the Sun goes behind that
mountain
oh oh that feels better without any
clouds or humidity in the air soon as
that sun goes away it gets so
cold look at this old
marker now this right here this is prime
Rock Tagan territory and I'm hauling 5
lbs of rifle up and down this mountain
if I don't at least see one I'm going to
be so
disappointed here's some little Pika
tracks those are tarmigan tracks right
there tarmigan have really distinct
Footprints because they have feathers on
their
toes right now I think I'm about halfway
to the top there's more tarmigan tracks
right there see that that's the wing
print in the snow on a day like today
they're going to be on the sunny side of
the
hills that's the next set of mountains
we got to get
over I just heard a rock tan make a
little croak over that
direction
oh we're in deep snow now and I don't
have snowshoes this path is pretty
packed and it's good if I take one step
off I sink way down I've got to stay on
the path well I've been walking uphill
for about 3 hours I'm going to take a
little snack break it's a cranberry
winley Dale
Cheese got this gorgeous Italian
salami
that is so good one wedge of cheese like
this can be over a th
calories every time I get stuck in one
of those holes it just takes so much
energy out of
me
I can see a ball up there a white ball
sitting right out in the
open yeah it's just a snowball those
white tagin sitting on top of the snow
will just look like a bunch of
snowballs
so the snow is getting deeper and the
Trail's getting sketchy I got to pick
where I step very carefully try to find
Footprints and step in
those
oh well like that that's straight up to
my
hip look at that
hole that's a that's a deep hole my
fingers are getting
Frozen
oh I made it I crossed the
mountain that's one side of the mountain
and this is another that big flat Smooth
Spot right there that's a glacier and
Glaciers can be a bit sketchy when you
get lots of snow on top of Glacier it
hides all the crevasses and you can step
through them and have big problems if I
stick to the trail I should be okay
okay it is so much colder on this side
of the
mountain
oh oh man that is a deep
one yeah my knee just did something
funny oh oh man I just did something to
my knee going to take an
Adil but every once in a while I'll do a
weird MO motion and it really
hurts so right now I'm crossing a
glacier it's a sheet of ice that's
thousands of years old and hundreds of
feet thick there's about four or five
feet of fresh snow on top of it and
that's what I'm walking on if you come
here in this summertime the snow will
have this white and blue color to
it I can see a group of bers coming down
the glacier I think we're going to have
some company
tonight look there it is there's the
cabin it's one of several survival Huts
here in these mountains it's one of the
nicer ones actually now you can look
over there those other mountains there's
Sou facing you can see how little snows
on there but we're in the shadow so
there's tons of
snow all right let me give you a
tour oh it's kind of warm in
here these windows have kind of made a
little bit of a greenhous effect in
here got this just epic view of the
mountains in the
glacier look at that that is gorgeous
got a couple bunk beds here nothing but
plenty of room to
sleep got a bunch of games and puzzles
in here entertain
people a lot of extra climbing equipment
whole bunches of pots and
pans and they got a kerosene heater in
here so that's for the kerosene
oil so you can actually crank this thing
up and get heat if you have kerosene
yeah there's the stove I didn't bring
any kerosene
though they got more room up here couple
extra mats and sleeping bags up there
well looks like we're going to have some
company we got uh looks like three
hikers and some dogs I'm not sure if
they want to be filmed or not so we'll
just kind of play it by
here hey how's going it's going all
right are you allergic to dogs I'm not
allergic not allergic I was filming a
video to put up my YouTube channel so if
that doesn't bother you I will complain
about the dogs just are you okay with
that I'll just I'll try not to be weird
about it well there's supposed to be
some good uh northern lights tonight
though yeah hoping to see that I hope so
too little bit oh you guys put the snow
in there there and oh nice right here
and then we'll just yeah haul it in when
needed
nice
well there's a lot of survival Huts
throughout the mountains here and most
of them are maintained by private groups
and clubs this one's owned and
maintained by the American Alpine
Club I think these survival Huts are
just an absolute amazing resource
there's several of them throughout the
mountains here they're free to use you
don't need any reservations the club's
just asked for donations or that you
sign up to be a member and it's usually
only like 30 bucks a year or something
like that there's No Reservations
they're kind of a first come first serve
and everyone just kind of crowds in and
makes it
work all
right
yet plus we saw a ton up there on the
balcony we got couscous with Craisins a
little bit of salt and oil and scooping
it up with a bit of pilot
bread they not that warm it's a pretty
good view right there are yeah
what so you're both 30 so I think people
were like
okay oh the sun's going down it's going
to get cold see those n going to light
up the kerosene stove here get this
place warmed up make sure this is up you
let that get out a little bit
more
kerosene doesn't blow up like gas yeah
you can actually put a match out in
kerosene if you just go like
that yeah that is
nice oh yeah oh look at the sunset over
there that's pretty hey
boys look at this what do you guys got
you got smoked salmon pesto pasta is
that sakey yeah oh that is good looking
sck eye there take my little couscous
and just go home yeah that that pesto
smells really good that smells really
good get a small one here I don't want
to be greedy oh look at that it's not
overdone that's nice this nice a good
salmon flavor that's a subtle smoke yeah
very subtle
mm haven't had much I know there you
go hey that is a fluffy dog that's
that's Huckleberry hey Huckleberry oh
nice oh nice that's cozy oh are you
offering these oh but we have to cook
them first they brought cookie dough and
they're going to cook it on a skillet I
want to see this this is going to be
good what's going on oh my God having
raised three kids this looks a little
bit like something I had to deal with
for a while
but that is a nice bake right there side
look at those Beauties much look at
thatof road trip
wow pumpkin chocolate chip that's good
good chocolate chip I got heat got
company this is not what I'm used to
this is pretty bougie camping here I'm
coming I'm coming coming all righton all
right we're supposed to have really good
northern lights tonight so I'm going to
set up a whole bunch of time-lapse
cameras over on the
left I go in and play some cards yes you
saw oh Puffy shoe buddies twinsies
camping slippers are the Lo luxury item
I'm never going back on oh they're
brilliant got the chocolate covered
hazelnuts
here when you count your cards at the
end so all all face cards are worth 10
so
14 yes
I'm all already got my hot water water
bottle check for leaks go throw up my
sleeping bag I demand a certain standard
of warmth when I get into that
bed goat hunt we went out any time I've
ever repaired up one in all my
inflatable pillows have holes in them
right now so I grabbed this thing it's a
waterproof pouch and turn it inside out
and it's got like a Chenille or
something on one side so the HG one that
has they're like stuff well there we go
they got my puppy jacket in there and
nice little
pillow yeah dog's got a nice little
setup there here hey boys all right guys
I think it's time to hop in my sleeping
bag I will see you guys in the
[Music]
morning
[Applause]
[Music]
well good morning guys it's about 8:30
in the morning and uh just starting to
see a little bit of color over the
mountains the why why am I get to
flavored sugar I'll tell you what this
cabin did really well staying warm just
with us inside it it stayed around 45 to
50° and we didn't have the heater on at
all so it's uh it's pretty cozy in here
what you got going on here tea steeped
coffee actually oh steep oh steeped
coffee and donuts classic right oats you
got some quick oats some cinnamon
raisins
there there are definitely those and
there's and then you can go
and
um yeah yeah so I forgot to bring a
plate or a fork or that so we we're
going to eat this like a giant
cracker no that'll
work
I think it's just amazing that this area
is just open to the public to anyone to
use to come and enjoy and if you want to
do your part and support the American
Alpine Club who maintains this I'm going
to put a link in the video description
below to their
website you can see here they've got a
million signs saying don't put toilet
paper in the ouse instead you burn your
toilet paper right in there you a little
lighter there's just a giant bin down
here in the bottom that collects all the
waste and once a year the American
Alpine Club has to hire a helicopter to
come and pick up that barrel of Pooh and
take it away so because of that people
say don't pee in the out housee and
don't put toilet paper down there you
got to save all that room for
solids I can hear some rock to aragan
chirping just over there in that
Valley that's a bit of a hike
though
okay
yeah do
not yeah I did contribute some pink
stuff out here I wish I had a pack
dog dang all right guys we're getting
ready to pack it up and head back and uh
my knee is feeling pretty good I'm
hopped up on Advil I'm optimistic I'm
optimistic
I think think it'll work
out hopefully we should have better luck
walking on the snow coming down it's
colder so the snow is sturdier just need
to take it easy I don't need to punch
through and twist my
knee well that group I Shar
oh oh that all the way up to my
back oh that's a deep one
o I got snow up the back of my shirt on
that
one oh that group I shared the Hut with
were just really nice people I really
lucked out there one of them was a
rescue swimmer for the Coast Guard had
some really interesting
stories it's kind of slick here here so
I'm going to pull out my
[Applause]
cleats it seems a lot Slicker today and
it's a little rougher going downhill
when it's
icy pancake break all
right there's some
crowberries that was a good
crowberry
these poles are great on these steep
hills take the stress off my knees and
help me keep my
balance check it out that's a magpie
Nest magpies build roofs on top of their
nest to protect their
[Applause]
babies that was a lot of work but I hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you want
to see more videos from the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel make sure to click
subscribe and check out our video
playlist we have all of our videos
organized by topic there I'll see you
guys next video If you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
Boys YouTube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this and
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button so you'll get notifications
thanks for
watching